if you filled up recently you definitely
noticed the pain at the pump the average
price of gas in nevada
is three dollars and 67 cents a month
ago
we were at three dollars and 61 cents we
are rounding out the top three
in the nation preceded by california and
hawaii sally jaramillo takes a closer
look as to why the prices
continue to rise
paying at the pump nevada gas prices are
one of the highest
in the nation so if you're traveling by
car this summer
don't expect them to go down anytime
soon
jeremy aguero is the principal analyst
with applied analysis
he says right now global demand is
escalating for crude oil
as economies rebound from the pandemic
and it's higher than anticipated
some of the weather related conditions
that affected some of the refineries
there's a natural transition as we
switch over from the blend that's used
in the wintertime to the blend that's
used in the summertime for some of the
western states there's also some high
taxes that are imposed on gas
prices lots of people moving in from
california means more demand
and not to mention leisure travel is up
tremendously
sam's club in costco are showing the
cheapest prices in town however you can
find the least expensive gas where you
live by going on
gasbuddy.com grocery stores like smith's
offer field points that can lower the
price too reporting sally caramillo 8
news now
will valley drivers listen up tomorrow
mosaic church in henderson is offering a
dollar off every gallon of gas sold
the event is this saturday from 8 a.m to
noon at the chevron
of saint rose and the 2 15. volunteers
will be on hand to
pump gas and wash windows there will
also be discounted car washes again
that's this saturday
from 8 o'clock to noon